salut les épis curieuse et les épis
curieux au cinéma on adore les films
catastrophes cataclysme climatique
déluge invasion extraterrestre tous les
scénarios ou plutôt scénarii
apocalyptique existe et pourtant de
véritables désastres peuvent nous tomber
sur la tête vous aviez aimé ma
précédente vidéo top alors c'est reparti
pour mon top 5 les catastrophes
naturelles qui peuvent vraiment se
produire
première catastrophe le big one
direction la californie il s'agit d'un
séisme dont vous avez sûrement déjà
entendu parler c'est un tremblement de
terre dévastateur qui peut ravager la
côte ouest des états unis à tout moment
selon les prévisions des scientifiques
ce séisme pourrait atteindre une
magnitude de 8,2 à 8,4 vous donner une
idée le séisme survenu au japon en 2011
à l'origine du tsunami a atteint une
magnitude de 9,1 sur les estimations
dans le pire des cas le big one pourrait
faire plus de 1800 morts et cinquante
mille blessés il causerait 200 milliards
de dollars de dommages il faut dire que
la californie est une zone propice aux
phénomènes sismiques de grande ampleur
depuis la frontière mexicaine
jusqu'au nord de san francisco sur
l'océan pacifique ces tirs la fameuse
faille de san andreas elle sépare deux
plaques tectoniques la plaque aux
siennes pacifique et la plaque
continentale nord américaine la première
coulisses le long de la seconde de
quelques centimètres par an en surface
ça ne se voit pas mais dans le sous-sol
les charges s'accumulent jusqu'au moment
où les forces tectoniques sont trop
importantes et que le sol cède le
décrochage est alors très rapide et très
violent et provoque un tremblement de
terre pour l'instant les scientifiques
ne peuvent pas encore prédire les
séismes avec précision pour le big one
la question n'est pas de savoir où mais
quand il se produira ce que l'on sait
c'est que la faille de san andreas
active tous les 150 ans environ à chaque
fois l'immense secousse frappe la côte
ouest américaine le dernier séisme de
grande ampleur qui s'est produit dans la
région a eu lieu en 1906 il a causé la
mort d'au moins 3000 personnes certains
sismologues estiment que le big one
aurait 62 % de chances de frapper san
francisco dans les dix prochaines années
deuxième catastrophe qui se produira un
jour ou l'autre l'éruption du vésuve
dans la baie de naples avec deux autres
volcan italien elle est là en sicile que
le stromboli ge à côté c'est l'un des
volcans les plus actifs d'europe c'est
aussi l'un des plus surveillées au monde
et le premier à l'avoir été ses
éruptions sont imprévisibles et peuvent
prendre plusieurs formes elles peuvent
être effusive ou explosion les éruptions
effusive sont caractérisés par de
grandes coulées de lave très liquides la
température de la roche en fusion
atteint plus de 1000 degrés elles
détruisent tout sur leur passage mais
laisse le temps aux populations de fuir
les éruptions explosives sont beaucoup
plus dangereuses sous l'effet de la
pression le bouchon qui ferment le
volcan explose projetant dans
l'atmosphère des gaz et des cendres
incandescentes qui ensuite dévale les
pentes à plusieurs centaines de
kilomètres par heure ce sont les
fameuses ne les ardentes l'éruption la
plus célèbre et la plus violente du
vésuve remonte au 24 août de l'an 79
elle avait alors détruit toute la région
et enseveli les villes romaines
d'herculanum et de pompéi sous la cendre
mais ce n'est pas la seule éruption
cataclysmique du vésuve après plusieurs
siècles de silence le volcan s'est à
nouveau activé en 1631 l'éruption a tué
quatre mille personnes et fait
d'importants dégâts dans un rayon de 500
km au fil des années le volcan a connu
une cinquantaine d'éruption plus ou
moins importantes la dernière remonte à
1944 depuis le vésuve est endormi mais
pas éteint selon les scientifiques il
devrait se réveiller un jour ou l'autre
et les conséquences pourraient être
dramatiques 4 millions de personnes
vivent aujourd'hui dans l'agglomération
napolitaine troisième catastrophe
on continue avec un ange est venu de
l'espace mais non il ne s'agit pas de
lâcher météorite imaginez un black out
durant plusieurs semaines plus
d'électricité plus de communication des
villes renvoyé au moyen âge eh bien
c'est ce qui pourrait nous arriver en
cas de super tempête solaire alors de
quoi s'agit-il eh bien le soleil et mais
sans cesse des rayonnements il y à la
lumière bien sûr qui nous éclairent il y
a aussi des rayonnements nocifs c'est le
champ magnétique de notre planète qui
nous protège de ces radiations le
problème c'est qu'il arrive parfois
suite à une perturbation à la surface du
soleil qu'une grande quantité de
rayonnement soit libérée c'est ce qu'on
appelle une éruption solaire elle se
traduit visuellement par un flash
lumineux à la surface du soleil
attention quand je dis visuellement on
ne peut pas le voir à l'oeil nu d'abord
on ne regarde jamais le soleil sans un
dispositif adapté ce flash correspond
aux rayons ultraviolets et aux rayons x
qui sont invisibles à l'oeil nu ses
éruptions sont parfois accompagnés de
gigantesques jets de matière dans
l'espace par là lors de tempêtes
solaires et lorsque la terre se
retrouvent sur leur trajectoire elle
subit ce que l'on appelle d'un orage
géomagnétique des tempêtes solaires
peuvent ainsi perturber le champ
magnétique de notre planète irradié nos
satellites et endommagé les réseaux
électriques le 10 mars 1989 au québec à
cause d'une tempête solaire plus de 6
millions de personnes se sont ainsi
retrouvées sans électricité pendant neuf
heures aujourd'hui en cas de super
tempêtes solaires les infrastructures
technologiques du monde entier
pourraient être paralysés vous imaginez
non seulement il n'y aurait plus
d'électricité mais + télévision + de
radio on perdrait les signaux gps on
pourrait même subir une panne complète
du réseau internet évidemment on se
serait un peu compliqué pour regarder
epicure yeux sur youtube au passage si
ce sujet sur les tempêtes solaires vous
plaît n'hésitez pas à le signaler en
commentaire j'y consacrerai une vidéo
complète 4 1 méga tsunami pour évoquer
cette catastrophe on repart aux
etats-unis dans l'océan pacifique
c'est ce que l'on appelle l illinois
il s'agit de l'effondrement d'un volcan
situé à hawaï qui déclencherait un méga
dessus elle selon certaines études le
mot kilauea volcan le plus actif d'un
rail se déplace à une vitesse moyenne de
10 centimètres par an le volcan
glisserait ainsi progressivement vers
l'océan pacifique
en cas d'effondrement il pourrait
déverser environ 12000 kilomètres cubes
de roches dans l'océan le choc moment de
l'impact pourrait alors généré un méga
tsunami atteignant la côte ouest de
l'amérique du nord même los angeles
situe à 4000 km de hawaï pourrait alors
être touché les tsunamis sont des vagues
géantes qui se produisent à cause d'un
tremblement de terre ou de l'éruption
d'un volcan sous marin mais ils peuvent
aussi se produire lorsqu'une immense
quantité de débris tombent dans l'océan
ainsi un éboulement colossal où la chute
d'un astéroïde peut provoquer des vagues
atteignant des dizaines voire des
centaines de mètres de hauteur sur le
territoire français le danger existe
aussi à mayotte précisément dans l'océan
indien la bave un volcan sous marin a
été découvert en 2019 son activité
génère de nombreux séismes sur l'île
mais le plus grand risque c'est le
glissement de terrain celui ci pourrait
engendrer un tsunami il ya déjà eu des
antécédents de ce type dans le monde en
1958 dans la baie de liqya en alaska un
tremblement de terre de magnitude 8,3 à
provoquer un éboulement gigantesque 30
millions de mètres cubes de roche et de
glace se sont effondrées dans l'eau
provoquant une vague qui au contact de
la cote est remontée jusqu'à une
altitude de 520 mètres 5e et dernière
catastrophe l éruption d'un supervolcan
il se trouve au nord-ouest des
etats-unis dans le parc de yellowstone
beaucoup de touristes s'y rendent pour
profiter des paysages et assister
notamment au spectacle des geysers mais
peu de gens au final savent que ce parc
se trouve sur un gigantesque volcan il
faut dire qu'il n'a pas la silhouette
classique d'un volcan il ne ressemble
pas au vésuve au contraire ils font de
ce que l'on appelle une qu'albert à une
vaste dépression de 65 km de large
caldera est d'ailleurs un nom d'origine
portugaise qui signifie chaudron elle
s'est formée cette can des rares il y a
près de 630 millions à la suite d'une
violente éruption volcanique et l'énorme
réservoir de magma qu'on appelle aussi
chambre magmatique contient encore de la
roche en fusion qui pourrait provoquer
une nouvelle éruption sur terre il
existe 20 super volcan comme le
yellowstone et ce sont de véritables
dangers pour l'humanité en cas
d'éruption massive ils peuvent rejeter
des dizaines de millions de tonnes de
cendres et de dioxyde de soufre dans
l'atmosphère
ces nuages empêcherait les rayons du
soleil de passer provoquant un hivers
volcaniques c'est à dire une chute
brutale des températures pendant
plusieurs mois voire des années des
pluies acides détruirait également les
sols et polluerait les eaux bref un
véritable cataclysme dont pas de panique
et les scientifiques estiment que les
champs annuel d'une éruption de ce type
sont de 1 sur 730 milles c'est parce
qu'il va m'empêcher de dormir et à bien
pire en ce moment merci d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo c'est le meilleur soutien
que vous pouvez apporter à la chaîne si
certains sujets vous tiennent à coeur et
que vous souhaitez que je les traîne
dans ce format surtout n'hésitez pas à
les proposer dans les commentaires et
comme d'habitude si la vidéo vous a plu
ne vous gênez pas cliquez là et abonnez
vous à très bientôt les épis curieuse et
les épicuriens
[Musique]